[BIRDS CHIRPING]
[BELL RINGING]
You've reached Section
4 of the course.
Now it's time to see how you
can integrate the JSON search
capabilities that were
introduced in Section 3
into your application.
We'll look at examples written
in Python, .NET, Node.js,
and Java.
You'll learn how to query
a collection of documents
with the Redisson clients.
Remember that to be
successful in this course,
you don't need to know all
four programming languages.
While we'd recommend that you
read each unit that follows,
feel free to focus
on the languages that
are relevant to your
application development
needs and personal experience.
It's also important
to note that you
don't have to use the
Redisson clients to leverage
functionality from
RediSearch in an application.
The lower-level clients
redis-py, Node Redis,
and Jedis all include support
for RediSearch commands.
And StackExchange.Redis
allows you
to run these commands using the
generic ExecuteAsync function
to send arbitrary
commands to Redis.